Hilary Clinton says you are complicit in
murder if you disagree with her on gun
control policy Jimmy Kimmel is back for
more and it appears the Secretary of
State called the President of the United
States in effing at some point in
the recent past yes all of these things
are really happening I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show the
inevitable decline into stupid continues
and we will cover all of it the the
Rexel arson thing is pretty amazing I
mean he actually there's a report from
NBC News that suggested that he'd called
the president a back during the
summer and instead of him just sort of
brushing it off he decided to do a
full-fledged press conference so we have
a clip of that and we'll show it to you
a little bit later because it's pretty
amazing plus Jimmy Kimmel just couldn't
leave well enough alone he decided to go
back on the air last night and and
double down on the you're mean and cruel
if you disagree with me on gun control
so we'll go through all of that but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at helix sleep so lately I
have not been getting a lot of sleep why
well the last couple of nights it's
because I'm on the road guess what I'm
not sleeping on when I'm on the road my
helix sleep mattress helix sleep is the
best mattress there is in the world like
a helix sleep comm slash Ben you take
there to sit there simple two to three
minutes sleep quiz when they they'll do
a custom mattress that will be the best
thing you have ever slept on for couples
they can even personalize each side of
the mattress everybody from GQ to Cosmo
to the New York Times they're all saying
that helix is fantastic because it is in
it's a no risk proposition so you go on
you fill out their algorithm they send
you the the mattress in the mail you
unwrap the box and it inflates right in
front of you because it's foam and then
you sleep on it it's great you try it
for a hundred nights if you don't like
it they'll come they'll pick it up
they'll refund you the money so no risk
helix sleep calm slash Ben right now you
got 50 bucks toward your custom mattress
that's again helix sleep comm / Ben 50
bucks toward your custom mattress and
that is helix that is helix sleep calm /
Ben for 50 bucks off your order okay so
a lot going on in the world we begin
today with more fallout from Las Vegas
so president Trump yesterday he did sort
of what he likes to do when he's asked a
question that he doesn't know the answer
to which is he says I'll think about it
so yesterday the media asked him about
gun control and here was Trump's answer
we have a tragedy
and what happened in Las Vegas is in
many ways a miracle the police
department has done such an incredible
job and we'll be talking about gun laws
as time goes by okay so the very end of
it is what people are focused on the
left is focusing on where he said that
what happened in Vegas was a miracle of
course he's only talking about the law
enforcement response he's not talking
about the shooting itself people taking
him out of context here are ridiculous
clearly he's not talking about Americans
being murdered being miracle but it's
that last part he says we'll talk about
gun control as time goes by that has a
lot of people on the left very hopeful
now is Trump actually gonna pursue that
no he's not gonna person with any of
that
that's Trump's go-to when he doesn't
know what to say or he just wants to say
something to to leave the media with
something to think about but the reality
is that Republicans are not pushing gun
control right now because no gun control
measure that I can think of or that
anyone on the Left can think of would
have stopped what just happened in Las
Vegas why because it was unprecedented
because it was unthinkable and because
the guy bought all of his guns legally
or at least the ones he used legally
apparently and because he passed all
federal background checks had no
symptoms of mental illness from what we
know that's what makes this whole thing
so mind-boggling this this whole this
whole deal so one of the things the
left's been doing is I discussed
yesterday at length with Jimmy Kimmel is
they have been jumping on their high
horse and suggesting that if you
disagree with them about gun policy it's
because you're bad now in order to do
that very often what the Left likes to
do is trot out people who have been
victims of gun violence people who are
shot and they say well these people know
better than anyone as you know I'm not a
fan of this procedure this technique I
don't think that you being shot makes
you an expert on gun policy any more
than I think you being sick makes you an
expert on health policy or you paying
taxes makes you an expert on tax policy
right you actually have to study issues
in order to have expertise on them but
one of the things I find really
fascinating is that if you are a gunshot
victim and you disagree with the left
they just pretend you don't exist so
Steve Scalise he's probably the most
famous gunshot victim in the country at
this point Steve Scalise of course the
Louisiana Congress person who was shot
by a crazed Bernie Sanders supporter in
the Congressional baseball shooting just
a few months back and Steve Scalise was
asked specifically about Las Vegas and
the Second Amendment and here was his
answer inevitably questions about
the Second Amendment are raised by what
happened in Las Vegas it happens almost
immediately have you your experience of
your own and what you saw in Las Vegas
has it changed how you feel about any of
that
I think it's fortified it because first
of all you've got to recognize that you
know when there is a when there's a
tragedy like this the first thing we
should be thinking about is praying for
the people who were injured and doing
whatever we can help them to help law
enforcement we shouldn't first be
thinking of promoting our political
agenda okay but he's not allowed to say
that Steve Scalise doesn't exist watch
as he disappears from the media even
though again he's the most famous
gunshot victim in the country right now
why because he still has principles and
he has good reason for this okay if
there hadn't been armed guards there at
the Congressional baseball shooting he'd
probably be dead now the fact is that it
was arms that stopped that that monster
that bad human being and its arms that
stopped the guy in Las Vegas is the
police don't approach the room the guy
doesn't shoot himself he just continues
firing down into the crowd again the
evidence that gun control would solve
any of the problems he saw in Las Vegas
is really weak or non-existent Leila
Brasco she's a statistician and former
writer at 5:38 and she has a Washington
Post column today that I think is really
worthwhile talking about how before she
started researching gun deaths gun
control policy used to frustrate her and
she used to be anti NRA and used to
think that shrinking magazine sizes and
all of this would actually help with gun
deaths and mass shootings and then she
did the research and she found that that
isn't true here's what she wrote quote
my colleagues and I had 538 spent three
months analyzing all 33,000 lives ended
by guns each year in the United States I
wound up frustrated in a whole new way
we looked at what interventions might
have saved those people and the case for
the policies had lobbied for crumbled
when I examined the evidence the best
ideas left standing were narrowly
tailored interventions to protect
subtypes of potential victims not broad
attempts to limit the lethality of guns
and then she talks about Australia she
says that Britain Australia didn't prove
much what America's policy should be
said neither nation experienced drops in
mass shootings or other gun related
crime that could be attributed to their
buybacks and bans she says as I said
yesterday mass shootings were too rare
in Australia for their absence after the
by that program to be clear evidence of
progress and she goes through all of the
all of the gun measures that have been
suggested and she points out that the
the next largest set of gun deaths after
suicide number one is suicides is all
stuff I said yesterday number one cause
of gun death in the United States and
suicide number two our young men aged 15
to 34 killed in homicide very often in
gang violence but the left never wants
to talk about that because that would
suggest different policies including
jailing people from gangs who commit
violent acts for longer periods of time
in order to tamp down crime I mean it's
really funny but what the same left that
says we need to let people out of jail
and saying we should put gun owners in
jail so the people actually commit
crimes of guns we should let out the
people who just own a gun we should
throw in this seems to be the logic of
some people on the left and that's a bit
of an exaggeration but not much of one
right the idea is that if you buy a type
of gun the left doesn't like you should
go to jail if you are in jail we have an
over population in prison problem we
have a we have a school to we have a
streets to jail pipeline it's just
foolish okay so we should release all
those people but we should put out wha
biting people who want to buy a gun that
you don't want them to have in jail none
of this makes sense none of it is
effective but again none of this has to
do with policy for the West the left
thinks that it's gonna win on emotional
lines because very often it does right
on health care policy the left does win
along emotional lines on gun control it
doesn't the reason is too many Americans
own guns too many people are familiar
with how guns work there are hundreds of
millions of guns in the United States of
America and the implication that
everyone who is somehow a gun owner is
part of this evil it's just absurd to
people that's not stopping Democrats oh
so Hillary Clinton yesterday she came
out and she said Republicans are
complicit in Vegas do you feel like
they're complicit the GOP the NRA and
the gun epidemic we're seeing in America
they are of course they are you know the
Brady Bill actually kept two million
guns out of the hands of people who
weren't supposed to have them if we had
gone forward with the background check
capacity that we should have had and
that it was up to date my gosh we
computerized everything and we can't
computerize that Dylan roof was never
supposed to get that gun that he used to
kill people at mother Emanuel Church in
Charleston because he had a pre
existing arrests that should have
disqualified him but the system you know
is deliberately kept all creaky and slow
this is beyond absurd this is evil this
is nothing but pure unadulterated greed
motivated by people who want to sell as
many guns as they can to engage in a
falsity of fear and rhetoric about why
everybody has to have guns okay what
absolute nonsense what absolute nonsense
so everybody who wants to be able to buy
guns legally these are the people who
are the problem and people are
deliberately keeping the system leaky
because here's the background I'm Dylan
roof just so you have the factual
background according to the New York
Times despite having previously admitted
to drug possession Dylan roof was
allowed to buy a 45 caliber handgun
because of mistakes by FBI agents a
failure by local prosecutors to respond
to a bureau request for more information
about his case and a weakness in federal
gun laws so what happened apparently the
authorities and ability to prevent Ruth
from obtaining the weapon highlighted
the continuing background check system
problem which was intended to keep guns
out of the hands of criminals despite
new procedures and billions of dollars
the federal authorities still do not
have a seamless way of examining
Americans criminal histories that
eliminates human error okay do you think
that Republicans don't want to eliminate
human error Democrats weren't in charge
of the government for a huge percentage
of the time right Barack Obama was
president when all of this happened he
could help facilitate this it's his FBI
rabbit somehow this is Republicans fault
right they're evil they're evil they
want people to shoot people so they can
sell more guns if you really believe
that you don't know any gun owners and
you don't know any Republicans the
Democrats though are starting to really
I think reveal and what they think about
gun owners and what they think about
guns which is refreshing I mean I like
when there's a little bit of honesty in
this process and in just a minute I'm
going to show you what Democrats have
been saying about what sorts of guns
they want to what sorts of guns they
were on a ban it's pretty amazing but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at blue apron so blue
apron is the number one fresh ingredient
recipe delivery service in the country
their goal is to make home cooking
accessible to everyone
now they cooking together builds
stronger family bonds make sure that you
eat healthier and in many cases it's
less expensive and then going to a
restaurant
because right now you can spend under
ten bucks per person for its delicious
meals here's some of the meals that they
are now serving okay the pretty sounds
pretty great cheesy chicken black bean
enchiladas and salsa verde a maple gravy
smothered pork chops I haven't had pork
I've heard it's good stewed collard
greens and sweet potatoes spiced
cauliflower and pepper with jasmine rice
and cilantro yogurt sauce I mean this is
gourmet kind of stuff and you can cook
it yourself when they send you the fresh
ingredients again for less than $10 per
person per meal they deliver these
seasonal recipes and you get a you can
choose from a variety of new recipes
every single week or it can let their
keulen area team surprise you they don't
repeat a recipe within a year so you
will never get bored so that's pretty
awesome each meal comes with a
step-by-step easy to follow a recipe
card pre-portion ingredients it can be
prepared in 40 minutes or less or less
so go and check it out right now
and when you do when you go to blue
apron comm slash Shapiro you got 30
bucks off your first meal with free
shipping $30 off your first meal with
free shipping by going to blue apron
comm slash Shapiro you will love how
good it feels and taste to create these
amazing home-cooked meals a lot of folks
in the office are subscribers to blue
apron for a reason blue apron comm slash
Shapiro it is indeed a better way to
cook use that slash up hero so that they
know that we sent you and also so you
get the $30 off your first meal with
free shipping okay so there's Hillary
Clinton doing the moral posturing and
the moral posturing is designed to
undergird a program of gun seizures how
could this have been prevented is there
a law congressman Hobbs ultimately said
yes he'd before a ban on semi-automatic
rifles like the ar-15 how about you
absolutely I mean let's just be clear
that the pace of these epic mass
shootings 10 or more people being killed
doubled after the assault weapons ban
expired that's not a coincidence I think
we also have to look at these
aftermarket modifications that allows
you fairly to turn an automatic weapon
turn a semi-automatic weapon into an
automatic weapon but will ya also don't
think we can be caught in this trap
I think the gun lobby wants you in the
wake of one of these mass shootings to
only talk about the policy changes that
would have affected the shooting that
happened the day before we have to get
back to the Evergreen changes things
like universal background checks that
frankly probably would have stopped
many of the other murders around the
country that happened on Sunday before
the shooting started in Las Vegas okay
so number one so again that is not true
many of the guns that are used in crime
I believe the majority of guns that are
used in crime are not obtained legally
the idea that in in mass shootings the
people are not going through federal
background checks is not true this
should go through a federal background
check I believe that I believe that the
shooter in the pulse nightclub shooting
went through a federal background check
so the idea that all of these these
measures would have stopped any of this
is not true but notice what he glosses
over there and that is that he says he
supports a ban on semi-automatic rifles
ok understand that's pretty much every
rifle in the country pretty much every
rifle in the country is a semi-automatic
rifle because again a semi-automatic
just means you pull the trigger ones and
one round is fired that's all a
semi-automatic means AR people think it
stands for assault right assault rifle
of course it does not okay ar-15 is one
of most popular supporting rifles in the
country you ban that you're talking
about either having to confiscate
literally tens of millions of these guns
from from law-abiding Americans or
preventing them from buying those guns
on the on the market right now with
federally licensed firearms dealers and
background checks in the whole deal
Democrats are starting to come out of
the closet as to what they want here and
Americans aren't gonna like it it's so
funny the Democrats after a mass
shooting me always think ooh now the
tide of public opinion is with us the
tide of public opinion is with the idea
that we're all together in this and we
hate mass shooters and we want them to
die and they're evil people we're all on
that but we're not all together on the
policies that you prescribe because the
policies you prescribe are very much
contra traditional American concepts
about freedom and liberty and gun
ownership it's not just Chris Murphy who
who's tried to make hay off of this you
also have people excuse me like Senator
Ed Markey from Massachusetts arguing
that that the founders didn't want
people to be able to purchase guns when
the Second Amendment was written and in
order to maintain a well-regulated
militia they did not have in mind
that people could purchase guns
indiscriminately go up into the top of
buildings and rain down this this
okay that's not true obviously that days
hundreds other people again the founders
so the founders did believe that you
should be able to own weapons that you
could use in the militia right that
meant a military grade weapon we're not
even talking about people owning
military grade weapons as I said
yesterday the difference between a
civilian AR and military IAR is
extraordinarily significant right a
civilian AR is a semi-automatic a fully
militarized AR right an m16 or m4 now
these guns are have the capacity for
burst fire or fully automatic since
there is a big difference but again all
this really is is the left attempting to
use emotion in place of of real policy
so you know kid Jimmy Kimmel was back
last night and Jimmy Kimmel is not
backing down off of his I am holier than
you are I care more about people who
died therefore you must agree with me
here's what he had to say last night to
critics like me who said that his gun
monologue last night was factually
incorrect I'm not gonna get deep into it
again tonight I said what I had to say
last night but I do want to say
something these nuts who spent most of
the day today on television online
attacking those of us who think we need
to do something about the fact that 59
innocent people were killed in every one
second okay so first of all we didn't
spend yesterday attacking people who
think that something has to be done we
attacked you for attacking Americans and
saying that Americans are basically a
bunch of dunderheaded cruel jackasses if
they don't agree with you on policy I
mean you actually wanna propose a policy
we can talk about the policy what I said
in the minutes after the shooting is how
about we get all the information on the
shooting and then we talk policy that
doesn't seem unreasonable to me now I'm
not saying we should never talk policy
I'm saying we should talk policy once
the information is in why is this a
difficult concept you know evidence
information but again and Kindle is
straw Manning here he's basically
suggesting that all of us who criticized
him we're really we just don't want to
do anything and that's why we're
criticizing him no I'm criticizing you
because what you're saying is factually
incorrect and then you're implying that
those of us who want evidence to back
our policies are somehow cruel and nasty
okay he continues talking about it
because it's too soon well maybe it's
too soon for you because deep down
inside you know in your heart you know
you bear some responsibility for the
fact that almost anyone can
weapon they want now you want to cover
yourself until the storm of outrage
passes you can go back to your dirty
business as usual but it's not too soon
for us because we're Americans and last
time I checked the First Amendment is at
least as important as the Second
Amendment so Jimmy I mean seriously this
is egregious stuff I hope you're a
better person than this but this is
really egregious stuff if I didn't think
you're a better person than this I tell
you to go to hell because that's that's
ridiculous okay for you to suggest go
back to your dirty business what's my
dirty business the same business as
yours okay
exercising my First Amendment rights to
talk about policy and politics okay the
idea that it's a dirty business if we
disagree with you I'm not selling guns
that's not what I do
okay I don't I've never sold a gun I own
two of them I have never sold a gun I'm
not in the gun sales business and it's
not a dirty business for people to be in
the gun sales business selling methods
of self-defense to to Americans who want
to defend themselves in their country
okay that's that's just insane but the
suggestion that I bear responsibility
for Vegas I had been responsible the
only person who bears responsibility for
Vegas is the guy who was pulling the
trigger on a bunch of people who are
innocent standing below if we're gonna
do that routine now if we're gonna
suggest that we bear responsibility for
our public policy choices with regard to
with regard to gun control then I would
suggest the Jimmy Kimmel bears
responsibility for every dead baby that
he backs through Planned Parenthood okay
that's it there's a significantly
greater connection between that Planned
Parenthood's sole goal is to kill babies
you know the goal of selling rifles is
not to kill innocent people and I don't
do that right I'm not saying that Jimmy
Kimmel is responsible for every dead
baby in the country because that's
absurd okay abortionist are responsible
for that I think he's wrong on policy I
think he's probably good-hearted for
Jimmy Kimmel to suggest that everybody
who disagrees with him again is just so
disgusting
for him to suggest that we bit I have
some sort of blood guilt on my soul and
that's why I don't want to talk about
this I've been talking about it all week
dude I've made my bones talking about
gun control and the case for and against
I know a lot more about it than Jimmy
Kimmel does and for Jimmy Kimmel to
suggest that anyone who wants to talk
about it who's not named Jimmy Kimmel
it's somehow motivated by their dirty
business their good deed I promise you
Jimmy Kimmel makes a hell of a lot more
money than I do
Jimmy Kimmel is making a
money off a lot of leftist who think
that he is just the bee's knees because
he does this kind of stuff so if we're
gonna talk about who's making more money
off political pandering Jimmy I don't
think that's a business you want to get
into okay but it's not just Kimmel even
even more objective journalists like
Chuck Todd are suggesting that you know
it's just a fear of talking about gun
control that's led to this impasse folks
there's no doubt about what the second
meant a Second Amendment does say but at
what point does a person's right to bear
arms start infringing on his neighbor's
right to live safely and freely and if
you've ever caught yourself checking the
exits while at a concert hall or school
assembly or a movie just in case you
probably already have are ready to have
that conversation you would think our
leaders should be able to have it too
well again I think there's actually a
pretty easy answer to Wednesday's my
neighbor's right to bear arms impinge on
my ability to live freely and it's when
he starts shooting at me that's that's
pretty simple answer Matt's like saying
when does your neighbors right to own a
sword impinge on your right not to be
chopped well when he starts trying to
chop me again I think there are
arguments to be made about what sorts of
you know machine guns have been banned
in the United States since 1986 I think
that's reasonable but you know firfer
but this suggestion that we have not
been having the conversation we have
it's just the left is angry because
they've been losing because they don't
have any evidence to support their
positions it's a and again it's just
infused the entire culture you can't
even watch sports anymore without this
routine Rachel Nichols on ESPN again
ESPN should be staying out of this but
we remember back in 2012 when Bob Costas
was doing halftime reports on the NFL I
need decided to inject his own politics
now we've got Rachel Nichols doing this
on gun control officials say this is the
deadliest mass shooting in modern US
history the phrase I guess they're
getting used to because it was only 14
months ago they were saying that about
the shooting in Orlando the orlando
shooting claimed more lives than
virginia tech now this one claims more
lives than what happened in Orlando I
don't know how we're gonna solve the
debate about guns in this country I just
know that while we're all arguing the
body counts keep going up and also we
have to stop are you safe right you know
we have to stop arguing is what she's
saying and the only way to stop arguing
is for us to agree with her I do love
that the talking points for Chuck Todd
and Rachel Nichols are
identical with regard to these mass
shootings as I said yesterday using mass
shootings as your gage of gun control
policy is actually a foolish idea
because they are not representative of
the broader whole I'm not the only one
saying that 538 says that okay nate
silver's site says that nate silver is
no right winger on guns and then of
course you have the greatest of all
political commentators of the left Keith
Olbermann so he attacked me on Twitter
this morning I had said yesterday who
made Jimmy Kimmel the moral arbiter and
Keith Olbermann tweeted because
like real Donald Trump the GOP and ben
shapiro have sold their souls to the nra
and the death cult
any other questions kid so a few things
number one is the suggestion that every
single person in the united states who
owns a gun and believes in gun rights is
part of a death cult because i think
that again death cult could be more
properly attributed to people who think
the Planned Parenthood is doing
wonderful work in killing babies but I
actually did have some questions for
Keith Olbermann that I tweeted back at
him questions like if you are so good at
your job why have you been fired from
your last 3297 jobs also was it his
expertise in shouting things like n
Fuego that gave him the godlike ability
to see into other people's souls was it
that and also where to get his glasses
because those are actually kind of nice
and then also is he just okay is he okay
because he doesn't seem okay Keith
Olbermann but this is the entire moral
equation the left wants to set up and I
just find it despicable I find it gross
okay so I'm gonna talk about Puerto Rico
and the Secretary of State apparently
calling the president the before I
get to any of that I first want to say
thank you to our sponsors over and my
Patriots apply so if you feel like it's
like things are chaotic if you feel like
there are threats from foreign places if
you feel like you look at North Korea
and is threatening and you look across
the sea and there are foreign threats
and there are natural disasters and you
figure you know what might be a good
idea having some food in the house in
case things go bad well that's why you
need to spend ninety nine bucks and get
a hundred and two servings of breakfast
lunches and dinners from my Patriot
supply this is their survival food
supply for just $99 and right now you
can order it at eight eight eight eight
oh three 14 13 eight eight eight eight
oh three 14 13 or online and prepare
with been calm again just 99 bucks for
one hundred and two servings of
breakfast lunches and dinners so your
family's gonna be fed for a month right
because that means that if something
goes wrong you don't have to rely on the
government you don't have to
the grocery store beings being stocked
you're gonna be the smart one for
spending that 99 bucks putting the food
in the back of the closet forgetting
about it until you need it and then if
you need it you break into it and you're
good to go
888 803 1413 or prepare with Ben
comprehend comm every government agency
by the way says that you should have
these kind of food supplies on hand
you should again it's prepared with Ben
calm okay so meanwhile in in other crazy
news there's an NBC news report this
morning
that the Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson back during the summer said
that President Trump was in effing
I don't know why this is newsworthy
really I mean I assume that there are
people at this company right at daily
wire behind my back call me an effing
mathis I'm not gonna name names I assume
that there are people Austin I'm not
gonna name names who call me that and
that's fine because I'm the boss the
boss is always considered nothing more
on by the people who work for him there
is nothing new Under the Sun it seems to
me the best response to this could have
been and should have been really like
this is what we're talking about we just
had a mass shooting like four days ago
and Puerto Rico is half under water and
you're and we're gonna talk about like
whether the Secretary of State one time
said that the boss was in effing I
think that's really odd but because
President Trump is an egomaniac and
because everybody has to pay personal
homage to him Rex Tillerson was forced
to go out and do a press conference that
got extraordinarily awkward when he was
asked did you in fact call the president
nothing more on the main headline of
this story that you called the president
of and if not where do you think
these reports are how many I'm not going
to deal with petty stuff like that I
mean this is this is what I don't
understand about Washington again you
know I'm not from this place but the
places I come from we don't deal with
that kind of petty nonsense and it is
intended to know nothing but divide
people and I'm just not going to be part
of this effort to divide this
administration well that's not it out so
that's awkward and it'll be it'll be
entertaining to see president Trump's
response he obviously has been all over
Tillerson this week over in the North
Korea stuff teller sit-ins gonna go it's
just a question of when it appears by
the way the Trump administration is
going to do something good and pull out
of the Iran deal that is the latest news
I will bring you updates on that as they
unfold if it unfolds during the show if
not
you know we'll cover it over at Daily
wire obviously but that would be good
news that would also be over the
objections of Tillerson who's become a
rather marginal figure inside his own
State Department so all of this is quite
fascinating is it a dumbest story yes is
it kind of funny that the Secretary of
State called a press conference just to
not say that he didn't call the
President of the United States a
yeah I'm gonna go with that's not great
40 mega mega mega chests that's not that
didn't seem particularly brilliant to me
okay in other news that was not
particularly brilliant so President
Trump goes to Puerto Rico and he says
some stuff now all he had to do going to
Puerto Rico was basically go there and
look somber for the cameras because it
is a somber thing and help hand out
supplies do exactly what he did in Texas
right in Texas he did it right he did it
exactly correctly no criticism in Puerto
Rico for some reason it was like Trump
just decided that he that he wanted to
have some fun and so before he even gets
there first he says to Puerto Rico I
hate to tell you this but you've thrown
our budget out of whack which is a very
weird comment in the middle of a
hurricane relief effort here's the ears
from saying that iqbal vanie is here
right there and Mick is a judge of a
thing called budget now I hate to tell
you Porto Rico but you've thrown our
budget a little out of whack because
we've spent a lot of money on Puerto
Rico and that's fine we've saved a lot
of lives oh well you know there it is a
little bit they've thrown the budget out
of whack count how terrible so people
are like Oh what and then from today
said don't worry we're gonna settle
porto Rico's debt problem they're not
gonna have to pay their debts people on
Wall Street are gonna get hurt so what
happened to the Puerto Rican bond market
because everyone figured I'm not getting
paid back now so just good stuff from
from President Trump there I can't
imagine what Tillerson had to say about
it and then Trump did something that's
even worse in terms of PR here is
President Trump going out there and
throwing paper towels into the crowd
like Kobe Bryant's wishing jumpers if
you can't see this he is literally
standing there and taking paper towels
there are people right in front of him
who are just asking for paper towels and
there he is trying to flip them into the
crowd like
into the crowd like a child he's gonna
go out there with like a paper towel
cannon like he's in a baseball game and
everybody's looking at him incredulously
like really this is what we're gonna do
now Harry is just throwing things into
the crowd is that you'll get paper
towels and you'll get paper towels and
you'll get paper towels so I think that
this is absurd it's not good image I
mean for a guy who's made his career
based on image this is not a good image
you don't wanna look flip about
hurricane relief like if you're at a
blood bank you wouldn't start taking
bags of blood and flinging them around
the the blood bank it's it is kind of
hilarious
I have to admit I laughed when I when I
saw that um but you can always count on
the left to turn something that is a an
imagistic win for them into an imagistic
loss so instead of them just saying
inappropriate for President Trump to be
so flip about hurricane relief in that
that that picture is really not great
you know you want the president to be
taking this seriously instead you have
Democrats completely going off the rails
and suggesting the most absurd thing so
here is the the council speaker for the
New York City saying that Trump was
treating people like animals in Puerto
Rico this president needs to be called
out for his lack of seriousness to this
humanitarian crisis and this visit today
was an utter disgrace and an insult to
the Puerto Rican people to be throwing
and loving paper towels at us as if we
were animals you know it's really making
light of a situation that is very severe
throwing a test as if we were animals
like that wasn't what I got I got that
Trump is um well to use Rex Tillerson
sword in these sorts of situations a
like I just I I think this was
stupid I don't think it's malicious he's
he's like well these people are animals
it's like I'm feeding the monkeys at the
zoo I really don't think that that's
what's going through at Trump's head
again the left can't contain itself the
the mayor of San Juan who has been in a
in a hate hate relationship with Trump
for the last few days
Trump went to Puerto Rico was nice to
her and then she was nice to him for a
minute and then he left them and she
started ripping him again here she is
ripping the paper towel stuff this was a
PR 17 minute meeting there was no
exchange with anybody with none of the
mayors and in fact this terrible and
abominable view of him throwing paper
towels and throwing provisions at
people it's really it does not embody
the spirit of the American nation you
know that is not the land of the free
and the home of the brave that at the
beacon of democracy that people have
learned to look up okay so over the top
so again if Obama did this I'd be all
over him you would be too let's be real
about this we'd say he was being flip
about it but this it's not this is not
America this is not the beacon of
democracy like come on like everybody
just take it down and take it down a
level take it down a level and it was
the same thing the media has been just
over playing at and on everything they
can't just call it out to the extent to
which it's wrong they have to go over
over board by you know by leagues so
yesterday here was Trump praising the
low death count in Puerto Rico now that
is something that I mean it is worth
noting that Puerto Rico's had I think
about 40 deaths something that has
something that neighborhood which is
supremely awful when people were
comparing the Haitian crisis to Puerto
Rico however it is worth noting the poor
that Haitian that the Haiti earthquake
where that happened I think it was 2010
that the Haiti earthquake ended up with
the death of someone with a hundred
thousand people they Haiti earthquake I
want to look up the actual the actual
number of dead in the Haiti earthquake
but it was way higher than this and here
was Trump basically saying that it so
and the casualty figures by the way from
Puerto Rico where I'm looking it up
apparently it's anywhere from a hundred
thousand to three hundred thousand
deaths in Haiti in Puerto Rico we are
talking in the dozens and that is
largely due to a you know the federal
governments or at least in part due to
the government's ability to bring aid in
timely fashion in any case here is Trump
basically saying that and then the media
goes nuts anyway but I'm just very very
proud of the fact that you know if you
look at just one statistic 16 deaths
that's a lot of this far too many deaths
but 16 if you look at Katrina they had
in the thousands and this was a storm
the likes of which nobody has ever seen
and you know we had FEMA here before the
storm even came they were on the island
during the storm and they were on the
island before the first storm you got
hit by two hurricanes so we're very
proud of the job we've done very very
proud and now we'll have to try and get
them back the power is slowly getting on
and the roads are open the runways are
open so these people that you've met
today or
the different people first responders
these are incredible people okay so that
seems relatively unobjectionable to me
didn't stop CNN's Christian Lisa from
going off on Trump
the clip you played Brooke is pretty
damning I I think sort of you know using
death counts as a talking point for how
successful he's been in making a joke
about how this is gonna run over the
budget but there's so much in that
there's 13 minutes of video and audio
there he talks about how the weather is
usually so great in Puerto Rico you know
there's video of him sort of throwing
food out like he's sort of a dime-store
Santa Claus to people I mean this is
even for Donald Trump who is a breaker
of political convention who is I think
defined the presidency downward and okay
everybody calm down everybody's calm
down are people getting what they need
in Puerto Rico if the answer is yes
everybody should be quiet if the answer
is no then we should all be all over the
administration okay and as far as the
image stuff goes yeah Trump sucks at
some of this stuff okay okay I mean I
really don't know what to say beyond
that okay so I do want to get to some
stuff I like and stuff I hate and a
little bit of Bible talk but before I do
any of that I first want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at texture comm
so as you know I'm an information
addicts that means that I read and read
and read and read and some of the stuff
I love to read is all the stuff from the
magazines well if you get a subscription
to a magazine these magazines off the
rack will cost you five six bucks right
now over a texture you're getting for
access to two hundred magazines then you
get a 14-day free trial right now
you got a 1484 trial and it's normally
$9.99 a month so first of all great deal
in the first place $9.99 a month and you
get digital access to over 200 magazines
but right now if you sign up a textured
calm slash pen you get a 14-day free
trial you can look back in their
archives it's entirely digital and they
have all of the magazines that you even
want to read everything from
Entertainment Weekly to Sports
Illustrated to National Geographic to
Reader's Digest again just for a
subscription one of these magazines it
probably cost you as much as the entire
the entire texture subscription excuse
me so go over and check it out right now
a textured calm slash pen again 14-day
free trial at texture calm slash Ben go
and check it out that lets them know
that we sent you as well terrific
service I use it my wife uses it we
really enjoy it okay
so but time for some quick things I like
and then some things I hate and then
we'll do Bible talk so first things I
like and then and then we'll break so
things things I like today the thing
that the thing that I like is a very
long thing I like so Malthus knows
because we traveled last week together
that the the TSA has some new rules and
and one of those rules is that you have
to take books out of your book bag
sometimes and so they picked exactly the
right day for this because I wanted to
look super pretentious and awful and so
the only book that I had in my backpack
that day was indeed Leo Tolstoy's war
and peace
so I'm midway through war and peace it
is extraordinarily long a lot of people
like the peace parts better than they
like the war parts I will admit that I
like Anna Karenina better than I like
war and peace so far maybe I will change
my opinion as it goes on but Tolstoy is
very lucid writer and a very easy to
read writer so anybody who says Tolstoy
is difficult no there are there other
Russian writers who are much more
difficult than Tolstoy the new
translation is quite lively and quite
good the one that I recommend is by
Richard PVR and Larissa Velikovsky
that's the one that I'm in the middle
middle of right now and it is it is
lively it is fun to read and the nice
thing is that it's written in the
serialized chapters so you can read it
three pages at a time it'll take you the
rest of your life but you can you can
read it that amount at a time and it is
indeed a good book so it has not been
overblown that this is a great book
because it is okay other things that I
like so yesterday when I was at the
California State Legislature and the
Republicans in the legislature had
invited me to speak on a panel about
hate speech and the Constitution so I'm
gonna look at what the the panel is
actually called it was actually called
combating hate while protecting the
Constitution okay so you would assume
that this would have something to do
with how to fight hate groups but half
of this was about stuff that happened on
campus like at Berkeley where I was
speaking so they were conflating two
issues there conflating the problem with
actual white supremacist groups and the
violence that's going on campus the
implication being that a bunch of hate
groups so-called hate groups are showing
up on campus or white supremacist groups
I like to be specific as when people say
hate groups sometimes it's like Southern
Poverty Law Center hate group which just
means conservative there too so they
were conflating white supremacists and
like any conservative who shows up on
campus and
sefa beats the crap out of people so the
Republicans wanted to have me come and
speak they wanted to have me on a panel
the Democrats in the state legislature
would not allow this they had 11
witnesses these witnesses included
people like Erwin Chemerinsky the Dean
of unit of UC Berkeley who spoke about
the First Amendment and is quite
proficient obviously they had a senior
investigative researcher from the ADL
they had a five person panel that was
basically an intersectional festival of
victimhood where people talked about how
much they were victimized by hate crimes
in California which is fine except then
there was a lot of talk about
intersectionality and the level of
political discourse and why the
relevance of your identity group is
relevant to the credibility with which
you speak which i think is a bunch of
nonsense and then finally they had a
bunch of people including Andrew
Greenwood who's the Chief of Police at
Berkeley so they ended up having as I
say 11 people on these panels but they
couldn't make any time for me on any of
the panels
despite the Republican request now
listen I'm not a victim that's fine I
don't care
they relegated me to the they relegated
me to the public comment portion of this
so the public comment portion of the of
the hearing but you got two minutes and
two minutes only so I'm going to play
that for you but if you want to actually
watch it you're gonna have to subscribe
so for $9.99 a month you too can get a
subscription so daily wire calm you can
go check it out right now you get the
rest of today's show live to get the Ben
Shapiro show live every day video
version you get live and later you can
download the entire video version
without ads you get the michael knowles
show live you get the Andrew Klavan show
live you get all of them on video it to
be part of our mail bags you get to
correspond with us which is awesome and
if get the annual subscription for 99
dollars a year then you get the leftist
here's hot or cold tumblr the world
famous tumblr that all seek but few have
achieved you can get that with an annual
subscription so go over to daily wire
calm right now and check it out and by
the way it helps us with with making
sure we can get the podcast on every day
and continue to bring you great content
so that is always very helpful to us so
please subscribe if you haven't done it
yet or if you just want to listen later
then download it iTunes SoundCloud
subscribe at YouTube and then you can
you can listen later we always
appreciate you leaving a review as well
we are the largest fastest growing
podcast a conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
okay so as I say over at the California
Legislature yesterday I was given 120
seconds so everybody else was given 10
minutes 15 minutes trim rinse gives
given half an hour I always given two
minutes in public comment which is you
know they just open it up and whoever is
there can talk so here is here's a
little bit of tape of what I said I sort
of reamed out the Democrats on the panel
your job obviously here at the
legislature is to ensure that our
freedom of expression is maintained that
our First Amendment rights are
maintained and what that means first and
foremost in my experiences on college
campuses is that the hecklers veto must
be stopped so I was at Cal State Los
Angeles in February 2016 and there was
almost a riot there and the police were
not allowed to do their jobs and
students were physically assaulted in
the crowd it is the job of this
legislature to ensure that police can do
their jobs and when they do do their
jobs and they're allowed to do that a
places like UC Berkeley everything goes
fine and I'd like to make a point here
about UC Berkeley the reason it cost six
hundred thousand dollars to bring me to
UC Berkeley was not because of me
okay everybody keeps suggesting that it
was because I was coming I'm so
controversial and so terrible I came
exactly one year before and it costed
this many dollars it cost zero dollars
for security at UC Berkeley
the reason it cost $600,000 at UC
Berkeley is because an Tifa and violent
groups had decided that Berkeley was
their domain and they were going to be
able to run roughshod over law
enforcement there and this does bring up
one final point that I want to make in
the long period of time that I have to
discuss and that is the problem with a
legislative body such as yours trying to
draw a line specifically about what hate
speech constitutes because the fact is
that one of the reasons groups like Han
tifa's show up is not because they know
who I am it's because they have been
told by people that I am promulgating
hate speech which is utterly false and
utterly untrue
there are people who say vile things and
with him I disagree among them people
like milo gianopolous who sent me a
picture of a black baby on the day of my
child's birth because I wasn't
sufficiently standing up for the white
population supposedly but that does not
mean that the legislature gets to decide
what hate speech is I've been labeled
the promulgator of hate speech when I
was the number one target of hate speech
according to the ADL among the
journalistic community in 2016 so let me
suggest that as a legislature your chief
job is to ensure that my taxpayer
dollars in this state go toward making
sure
the people like me and people with who
might disagree get to speak in places
like college campuses and not toward
regulating what speech you find good and
what speech you find bad because it's a
really dangerous business and their
speech I don't like if their speech you
don't like but if we can't agree that
there's a difference between speech and
violence we're not gonna be able to have
a free state let alone a free country
thanks okay so I agree with me good job
mate
so there was the Sacramento Bee had an
entire editorial today that had done the
Democrats were for for barring me from
speaking essentially until public
comments and then then me getting up
there and smacking them so well done
Democrats as always undercutting your
own points on free speech okay so time
for a couple of quick things that I hate
okay so quick thing that I hate number
one so there's a pro-life GOP Congress
person whose name is Tim Murphy he's a
Republican Congress person he is a
pro-life guy and apparently according
the Pittsburgh post-gazette he asked his
mistress to get an abortion
so he's been representing Pennsylvania's
16th congressional district since 2003
he admitted to having an extramarital
affair last month his old lover is
accusing him of being hypocritical in
his pro-life beliefs apparently the the
Republican congressman's ex-mistress
texted well you have zero issue posting
your pro-life stance all over the place
when you had no issue asking me to abort
our unborn child just last week when we
thought that was one of the options and
then Murphy said I get what you say
about my March for Life messages I've
never written them staff does them I
read them and winced
I told staff don't write anymore I will
okay so he does not deny having asked
his mistress for an abortion gross there
are a couple things that are gross about
this one well many things okay number
one mistresses bad idea gentleman okay
it makes you immoral do not do this
number two asking your mistress for an
abortion your piece of garbage
don't impregnate your mistress don't ask
her for an abortion it's not the baby
fall babies fault your piece of garbage
and want to protect your political
career number three the media's spin on
this that a pro-life person asking for
an abortion is somehow significantly
morally worse than a pro-choice person
asking for an abortion
so hypocrisy is bad but I would rather
that somebody actually be pushing the
right standard and not living up to it
then that somebody'd be pushing the
wrong standard and living up to that
wrong standard this is one of my pet
peeves
I really don't like this stuff when
they're when they're Republicans who
fall short of a moral standard that
they've pushed the the people seem to be
much more angry that they upheld the
moral standard than that they broke the
standard so I'm angry to Murphy because
he didn't uphold the standard I'm not
angry to Murphy for saying the right
things about abortion I'm angry to
Murphy for doing the wrong things with
his mistress and with regard to abortion
I'm angry at his sin I'm not angry at
the standard that he was that he was
pushing in Congress that is the correct
standard I don't want to fall into this
trap of the easiest way in politics to
avoid being a hypocrite is to have no
standards right that's true the easiest
way to avoid being a hypocrite in
politics is to have no standards if you
have your Bill Clinton and you have no
standards about abortion or or sexual
promiscuity then it's very easy to get
away with crap I don't like that because
I think standards are important so I
think that we should relegate our
criticism of Tim Murphy to being a piece
of crap not to Tim Murphy his standard
on being pro-life I think that's silly
okay final thing that I hate this is the
last thing I hate you're getting for a
week and a half so treasure this take it
near to your heart Michelle Obama for
some reason has decided to emerge from
the woodwork again to talk about how
America's racist sexist pig and
homophobe this is 2008 Michelle Obama
not 2015 Michelle Obama who is popular I
don't you know I don't like this version
of Michelle Obama neither did Americans
in 2008 physically there's a difference
in color in the tone because one side
all men all white on the other side some
women some people of color and people
who look down at that and go yeah yeah
that looks good that looks right we're
probably getting a lot done and we're
doing it right you know I looked at that
and I go no wonder no wonder we struggle
no wonder people don't trust politics
it's not we're not going to notice
what these rooms look like number one
this idea that you know on the
Republicans they're all gray and white
that's the color palette on the other
side of the room
they're yellows and blues and whites and
greens and there's a difference on the
one because the left is just so much
better at doing things because you know
they actively have more people who are
people of color
again if you're judging somebody's merit
or their viewpoint based on their color
this makes you a racist by definition so
just because you happen to be black
person saying that doesn't make you a
non racist that's it's silly okay quick
Bible talk so this week the reason I'm
taking off time and taking my vacation
at the same time because I would have to
take the days off anyway is because this
week we celebrate Sukkot Sukkot is a
celebration in the Jewish calendar of
the of the wanderings in the wilderness
essentially we used to live in basically
booths and what Sukkot is supposed to
represent we actually go outside and we
eat in essentially a shack that we set
up it's it's three sides at no
two-and-a-half sides of minimum but
three sides usually that are sort of
made it's almost like a tarp draped over
over some poles and then you have some
palm fronds on top that's sort of the
typical way the Sukkot are done ahsoka
is just the the booth and it's supposed
to remind us of our time in the desert
and how fragile everything was and the
idea that the entire world is basically
that Sokka right your entire material
life is that Sokka we decorate it we
make it beautiful but in the end it can
be blown away quickly just like that and
we have to remember that there is a
deeper meaning to everything that we do
there's a whole wider world outside the
Soka our attempts to create a permanent
life for ourselves in this world are
essentially in vain doesn't mean you
shouldn't do it doesn't mean that you
shouldn't pursue a better life and a
more beautiful life for yourself but you
have to understand that there is a world
beyond this one the meaning beyond this
one and that investing solely in the
material is a mistake okay there's a
bunch of beautiful Commandments that
have to do with Sukkot one of them is
waving what's called the lulav and in
the end the etrog so the lulav and etrog
you may have seen videos of Orthodox
Jews doing this it talks about and in
the New Testament they talk about the
festival with the fronds okay that's
what they're talking about so the what
you're waving is you're waving a palm
frond that's basically tied up so it
looks like a stick almost and then on
one side you have Myrtle and on the
other side you have willow and then you
hold also together with
in etrog which is basically a Citroen
it's it looks like a lemon this with a
big lemon it's a different fruit but it
looks like a lemon in any case what are
these supposed to represent so according
to Jewish philosophy the lulav
represents people who study the Bible
but don't do good deeds or don't follow
the commandment the hadass which is that
the myrtle represents people who do good
deeds but do not study and the Arava
which is the the willow represents
people who don't study and also don't do
good deeds right it has no smell and no
taste is the idea so it's so that
represents people who don't study in
zone 2 good deeds and then the the etro
the the actual fruit represents people
who study and they also do the
commandments so and you hold them all
together and you shake them before God
right this is what you do you actually
take them and you shake them in the
middle of sort of we do some celebrating
and you shake it in the middle turning
during prayers what's the point here the
point here is that in Jewish philosophy
you need all of these elements to have a
nation it's not enough to have just
people who are the the righteous people
the people who both study and do good
deeds and fulfill the commandment you
need people who don't do either you need
people who study and don't do the good
deeds you need all of these people
together the Jewish people and and
people generally are composed of all
sorts of these people and we have to
recognize that our inherent value to God
doesn't necessarily lie only in what we
are individually but what we are
collectively and that is people who care
about one another people who try to help
one another and people who recognize
each other's weaknesses and still
recognize that we're brothers and
sisters I've talked a lot about unity
this week because in the aftermath of
something like Vegas it's easy to for us
to fritter to fragments and it's tragic
that we fragment if we're gonna come
back together we need to recognize that
it takes all types in the United States
in order to make a country and we have
to move toward the notion that we're
friends and not enemies or the country
is gonna fall apart and it shouldn't
okay so with that message I leave you
for a week and a half I will be back - a
week from Monday please as I said last
time no Disneyland if everybody keeps
ruining things so please get it together
everyone and stay safe out there care
for your families and I'll see you in a
week and a half after my vacation my
well-earned if I may say it vacation
we'll see after a week and a half
love to everyone and we'll see you then
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]